so i feel like there was a little bit of
disagreement with the 3ds game of the
year for me it was shovel knight but for
almost everybody else it was bravely
default
can you hear my prayers
really default sort of encapsulates so
many things that have been missing
from the final fantasy series
and not that that makes it a great game
but it is a great game with these things
it's got a wonderful combat system it
plays this sort of like risk reward
mechanic where you can sacrifice turns
to have an advantage in the future
got a great class system as well that
lets you you know take on different jobs
it's kind of like final fantasy tactics
in that regard the way it handled that
and the characters were pretty
interesting like a lot of times you get
like these
same tropes over and over again in rpgs
but some of these characters were flawed
you know like you didn't really know
what was happening with them a lot of
time there was really good depth there i
feel that it's a near near perfect
iteration of the jrpg genre as it stands
right now like you said it did final
fantasy better than final fantasy is
doing right now um that job class
there's there's too much to do you have
the job and the sub job then you can
describe like other abilities like
there's just so much to do and that
overworld is enormous one of the things
that we did discuss though in in our
deliberations for this is
the second half of this game in which
there's you know it's a bit of mixed
opinion out there about whether bravery
default kind of falls away after that
first sort of 20 or 30 hours or so um
you know i personally found that you
know it got a bit repetitive but you
know i think you guys were a lot more on
board with this i mean justin you were
mentioning that you played it for like
120 hours or something is that right my
clock at the end of the game did say
that i'd played for 120 hours
it has a bit of a grind at the end and
there were probably maybe i left it on
overnight once as i fell asleep playing
it because i was just sitting grinding
but i mean that also speaks to that
how much how much fun it is to level up
your characters to unlock new jobs and
just wanting to min max all of your
characters and like i loved bringing all
of my guys to max level by the end sure
i was tired
i was gonna say that game does what no
other jrpg lets you do and it lets you
choose your random encounter rate you
can either turn it off or turn it all
the way up and i think that that's like
i wish that was in every game now yeah
that's a great addition they actually
had to come out with a second iteration
of bravely to fall in japan
um for that option and they added a
bunch of other stuff and that's the
version we got which is great this is
one thing i argued quite a bit during
the meeting is like yeah there are there
is a point in the game where it sort of
begins to kind of take a dip but i don't
think that that overwrites what is so
great about the rest of the game up
until that point
so you know i mean
the other nominees were wonderful too
you know we had shovel knight theater
rhythm smash brothers professor layton
but
for so many reasons bravely default is
one of the best games that you can only
get on the 3ds
and it came out almost a year ago but i
know i still think about it and like you
i really cannot wait to play the sequel
father
i swear that i'll return to you
a proven warrior